a tan solo dos días del inicio de la
copa y seis por la crisis climática en
varias ciudades europeas los activistas
por el medio ambiente han salido a las
calles con sus pliegos de exigencias
desde glasgow la sede de la cumbre los
manifestantes de hoy en rebelión
exigieron el fin del vertido de petróleo
y contaminantes en los océanos sabemos
que todo nuestro sistema financiero está
involucrado en este momento en la
industria de combustibles fósiles y
tenemos que encontrar una manera de
salir de eso y mover el dinero hacia
soluciones climáticas en lugar de
causantes del cambio climático una idea
que comparten los activistas de londres
que en el corazón financiero de la
ciudad pidieron a los bancos que dejen
de financiar este tipo de combustibles
sosteniendo premisas cómo puede respirar
con el dinero una marcha a la que se
unió la activista de tazón bears jay de
hoy las protestas se centran en los
bancos y el gas y creo que nuestra
principal demanda es que dejen de
financiar nuestra destrucción porque
muchas entidades financieras siguen
cediendo frente a los combustibles
fósiles acciones en parís decenas de
manifestantes arremetieron contra la
banca energética total que el 20 de
octubre publicó un estudio que restaba
importancia a la emergencia climática
países como arabia saudita o australia
también han pedido a la onu que rebajen
sus demandas climáticas cuestiones que
se debatirán en la reunión con 26 del 31
de octubre al 12 de noviembre